quelqu'un essaie de tendre un piège à
l'eau
quelqu'un de l'intérieur
lorraine il y à un agent double qui
opèrent à berlin
[Musique]
trouver qui traque les agentes
et par le fait de confiance à personne
[Applaudissements]
votre contact et david percival été
votre première impression horrible perla
a ses propres règles
[Musique]
je n'ai absolument aucune confiance en
toi
[Musique]
vous m'avez envoyé dans un sacré merdier
mais vous le saviez déjà j'en suis sûr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouah
bouclez votre ceinture c'est beaucoup
le temps nous est compté
[Musique]
je suis impressionné
ah ah
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]